the entire time i knew thanos he only
ever had one goal
to bring balance to the universe by
wiping out half of all life
he used to kill people planted by planet
massacre by massacre including my own if
he gets all six infinity stones he can
do it with the snap of his fingers like
this
you seem to know a great deal about
fouls
gamora
this is the daughter of thanos
your father killed my brother
oh boy
stepfather
technically she hates him as much as you
do
families can be tough
before my father died he told me that i
had a half sister that he imprisoned in
hell
then she returned home
and stabbed me in the eye so i had to
kill her that's life that was nice
round and round
and i feel your pain i feel your pain as
well because i mean it's not a
competition but i've been through a lot
my father killed my mother and then i
had to kill my father that was hard
probably even harder than having to kill
a sister
plus i
came out with both my eyes which was i
need a hammer notice
how do i open this thing that's some
sort of uh
four-digit code maybe uh
uh
what are you doing taking your pod
no you're not
you will not be taking our pod today sir
uh well are you making your voice deeper
no you are
you're imitating the god man
it's weird no i'm not oh he just did it
again this is my voice
you mocking me
are you mocking me stop it you just
didn't do it again
he's trying to cop let me get you
something enough he's doing it we need
to stop thanos which means we need to
find out where he's going next no uh
he must be going somewhere no no nowhere
it's a place we've been there it sucks
excuse me that's our food not anymore
you